Ciao ragazzi bentornati a un nuovo video.
Oggi voglio farvi vedere come passerò da
questa cosa qui a questo
Non chiedetemi
perché l'abbia fatto, soprattutto non so
che cosa abbiate visto perché ancora non
ho visto il risultato, quindi potrebbe o
essere un qualcosa di pazzesco visto che
è la prima volta che cerco di farmi un
trucco da Drag Queen, oppure potrei
sembrare la Befana
Partiamo subito  con questo tutorial che io farò
assolutamente a c***o
non l'ho mai fatto in vita mia quindi vi chiedo perdono. Guru del make up, Drag Queen questo qui non è un
modo per prendervi per il c**o assolutamente, anzi
credo che l'imitazione sia la forma più
alta di rispetto.
Come mi sono preparato, ho visto un bel po'
di video di Drag Queen, che facevano
tutorial di make up e ho pensato quindi di
unire tutte le conoscenze che mi sono
fatto all'interno di un solo video
Un pochino come quando Neo di Matrix
impara il Kung fu e vedere che cosa esce fuori
Partiamo col primo step, che mi
fa un po paura, che è quello delle
sopracciglia, perché loro se le
cancellano e usano la colla
Oddio sa...che schifo!
In tutto questo c'è Luigi qua che mi sta piastrando la parrucca per dopo
Vado a fare una cosa che per me è molto
molto più pesante che mettermi ora sti
sette chili, non potete vedere quanti ne ho, di make up sulla faccia, che è quella di togliermi la barba
Vado...e torno subito
Sbam! Ragazzi, mamma mia sembro Renato Zero. Per un uomo togliersi la barba è un pochino come
salire sulla bilancia, vorrei dirlo, è un
atto di grande coraggio e ti ricorda
anche quanti menti nascondevi sotto
al pelo
Partiamo subito...ah quella parte che
preferisco, che è quella del lifting
Alcune Drag utilizzano questo, sia per tipo
nascondersi il coso e sembra... far...avete capito
Cioè far sembrare tipo che non c'è proprio niente
cosa che non farò su questo canale
perché farò solamente un trucco ma
lo usano anche per fare tipo un lifting,
che adesso vi farò vedere
Viene piazzato...qui
Un altro metodo è quello
di fasciarsi tutta la testa
Cioè massima stima per le Drag Queen,
credo di aver sbagliato tutto perché boh
mi sembro il dottor Spock in questo momento.
Temo di aver messo lo scotch troppo basso vero?
Oddio mo è icollato... Lo vado a fare di là
Ok. In questo momento calcolate che le mie
guance sono all'altezza delle mie tempie
Passiamo con la base. Tac, tac. Secondo me le sopracciglia è impossibile nasconderle
Ma è arancione questo? Questo
qui? Ok perfetto sto sbagliando
Mi sono rotto già il c***o. "Voldemort
Garda in camera faccio paura, cioè da fuori credo pure
ma in camera sono mostruoso. Sono terrificante. Le mie sopracciglia in questo momento sono due grumi...
però in camera non si
vede. E' finto quello che vedete sul web
Si è scollato tutto. Sapete qual'è la cosa bella?
Che non riuscite a vederlo
Comunque senza barba sul serio assomigli a Enrico (Luigi)
Pensa che appena mi metterò tutto il trucco assomiglierò a mi madre
Correttore
Fanno pure quella specie di triangolo aspetta...il triangolo, il triangolo il triangolo
Cioè le Drag diventano delle strafighe a un
certo punto. Cioè mi sembra che mi sto
travestendo da donna mollata dal marito.
Ma la domanda è "come fate ragazzi?!"
Ma è un bucio di c**o infinito. Io in questo momento se vado per strada abbaglio i gatti
cioè le macchine se mi vedono passare per strada mi
fanno i doppi fari perché
pensano che stia abbagliando. Faccio paura,
non capisco come questa cosa possa
diventare alla fine una "donna", e a questo
punto bisogna fare quella cosa che si chiama baking
Si prende un botto di cipria e la si mette qua sotto
Non credete ai tutorial facili su internet,
non sono per niente facili
Si io mi devo mettere un pochino di questo lì.
Ah no il naso fanno pure
Eccomi, semplice. Adesso prendiamo questa spugnetta,
pensiamo a...
Mi sto travestendo da zombie. Terrificante, mamma mia! Allora, cari Mangiamorte
C'ho na guancia scalata che sembra uscita dall'Oltretomba, l'altra è uscita da un carro de Rio
Prendiamo una polvere di contouring. Dobbiamo scalare
dei solchi in queste guance
Altrimenti RuPaul ci dirà di "Sashay away". Non mi
sento proprio a mio agio in questo momento
Cioè sono tipo una tredicenne che
sta sperimentando per la prima volta
coi trucchi, mentre si screpolano le
sopracciglia
Adesso sto facendo questa cosa che si
chiama "Sbam!". Si si si è quello che fanno anche loro
Io non capisco se è giusto, se è sbagliato
Perché ho deciso di fare
questo video! Continuiamo a scolpire non lo so
qualsiasi cosa, in  questo momento mi
sento Michelangelo. Ciao forestiero
Ok basta, basta! Potrei continuare
all'infinito a cercare di migliorare un
cesso, ma rimarrà un cesso. Ho optato per
un trucco, naturale ho pensato
Vorrei fare una cosa tipo "natural chic".  E' bello portar via pezzi de faccia
In realtà sto sperando di fare un qualcosa di alta moda e credo che questa qui possa essere un fallimento
Shakalakala shakalaka shakalakalaka
Un po' Black Swan. Category is "Mina all'obitorio"
Chi ha detto che Michael
Jackson era morto?! Chi sembro in questo momento?
Sembro qualcuno, qualcuna non lo so.
Senza esagerare
Yes baby. Il trucco si può correggere, è
come una tela, e tu sei l'artista o il vandalo
Io qui metto una linea che va verso
il fuori
che non ho minimamente controllato se è uguale all'altra linea che esce verso il fuori. Mmm sono cugine
Secondo me sembrerò co tipo 40 anni in più. Cioè praticamente facevo prima a non togliermi le
sopracciglia e a crea sti du boschi.
Io me sembro hashtag "stupito", così sempre
E comunque in camera sembra meno una m***a di
quello che è dal vivo. Pensate quindi che
cosa vedo io allo specchio
Senti stiamo a fa Drag...diamogli, cioè
perché sennò sembra che stiamo andando in
chiesa così. Questo è il pezzo più difficile di tutti
Allora io avrò bisogno sicuramente
di un qualcosa di brillante
Avevi dei glitter argento da qualche parte (Luigi)
Avevo dei glitter?
Oh. I brillantini stanno
facendo qualcosa. Bisogna illuminà
Ragazzi so che tutti illuminano, quindi illuminiamo qui
Perdonatemi, vi sto facendo perdere tempo.
E' grigio...vero? Cioè mi sono sbattuto del grigio la sopra
che non brilla manco un po'.  E tu che mi dici "Mmm così gioioso
felice del mio fallimento. Io in questo momento mi sono rifatto le sopracciglia
Lo sto facendo arrivare fino alle tempie
Alice mi regalò questi pennelli
quando iniziai a fare "Grase" e mi disse
"Ti torneranno utili, pensami quando li
usi". Io ti chiedo scusa Ali, perché adesso ti
sto pensando e sono mortificato.
Aspetta aspetta però se io faccio questo
di colpo sembra che sono convinto. Forse
me la porta a casa con un po' di atteggiamento
Non è giusto fermarsi, non è rispettoso
nei confronti di chi è arrivato fino adesso
con che stomaco.
Sfumiamo leggermente non tanto perché
sia importante sfumare ma perché così la butto un po' in
caciara
Matita bianca sotto l'occhio, "l'occhio"
Oddio c'hai gli occhi rossi rossi (Luigi)
C'ho gli occhi rossi rossi? So lacrime, fidati, non è nient'altro
Rosa del deserto,
anche perché mi sembra che tutto il resto
mi abbia veramente deluso e basta
Infatti...pure te. Aspetta aspetta
Com'è che fanno? Com'è che fanno? Prendiamo un po' di fix plus
Ok
Non serve a un c***
Queste da che erano cugine a che so
diventate conoscenti
E si. So storto
Ragazzi sto per farmi sette
paglia di sopracciglia
Sali qui... finisci lì
Preparatevi, ragazzi sto pe diventà Ursula. Sembro un Clown
Io non mi arrendo.
Cioè se tu pensi che io sono venuto qui per
tornare a casa in lacrime, sbagli di
grosso perché io a casa ci sto già
Guarda tu in camera non vedi, c'ho le sopracciglia ribaltate verso...
Cioè praticamente le ho prese "Aa"
Poi un po di Blush giusto per sembrare che c'ho un po' di
colore. Giusto per ricordare che sono vivo
Di colpo sembro vivo, ecco a che serve il Blush! Ciglia! Ciglia!
Si...non le taglio, non le so tagliare, che c***o mi metto a fa mo, Diego Della Palma, adesso
E' quello che dico sempre. Conoscere la teoria non è uguale a
saperlo fare, ed è la grande morale di oggi
Adesso faccio quella cosa che fanno tutti
Ma me le posso andare a mettere in bagno queste?
Ragazzi torno subito. Sempre più carico
sempre più stupita. Ma è vero che il mascara lo
metti per forza a bocca aperta?
Senti io il mascara non lo metto, perché ho paura che mi si stacchino le sopra...cioè le ciglia
Evitiamo di fare questo, questa sciocchezza. Ah no non
bisogna fare così
Alice aveva detto che bisognava fare così,
bisognava chiuderlo, aprirlo e basta. Dov'è?
Ce l'hai di fronte proprio a te garda affianco(Luigi)
Ma c'ho le ciglia finte, non vedo niente. Ah ok eccolo
Perfetto. Ho messo un piccolo puntino di illuminante sul naso, sto mettendo un pochino di illuminante la sopra
Quelli si sbattono l'illuminante ovunque
Ormai non  sto manco più sfumando, sto a fa er mascherone. Adesso vado a Mirabilandia nella
casa dell'orrore...dove lavoro. Basta, non ce la faccio più!
Ah le labbra faccio...cioè faccio...un bel pandoro no? Du gommoni. Ora sto rischiando Krusty il Clown
Non so che forma di labbra mi sono fatto. Si, ci stava lo nude
Pure l'accento sofisticato mancava (Luigi)
Non so chi sembro ma comunque mi dispiace per la persona alla quale assomiglio
E adesso, giusto
perché rimaniamo semplici, un po' di gloss
Ho sbagliato. Dai l'abbiamo capito che non ci so capace. Rimettiamo tutto dentro Amen, non è servito a niente
Parrucca? Aspè, ho messo tutto? Torno subito con
la parrucca. Sbam! Aspè
Oddio, c'ho un orecchio intrappolato da qualche parte
Sbam!
Questo è il risultato con diciamo una parrucca
gentilmente piastrata da Luigi
Posso dire una cosa? Na m***a!
Allora non lo so, a seconda dell'angolazione sembro qualcosa di diverso
Un po' Martina Pinto sotto, sotto steroidi
Vabbè che dire ragazzi, io... sta faccia stupita. Quale?
Una delle Olsen?
Questi trucchi da Drag sono fatti per essere stupiti
Ecco White Chicks (Luigi)
Sembro una di loro...non credo
Che dire ragazzi, io vi chiedo scusa ma allo stesso tempo vi ringrazio se siete riusciti a vedere questo video
fino a questo momento. E che dire, alla
prossima. Ah il mio nome!
Come c***o fate?
Il nome potrebbe essere un nome sofisticato... (Luigi)
No il mio nome
Jacqueline (Luigi)
Jacqueline. Jacqueline Salary.  No io c'ho un nome che ho nel cuore
che è Sheila Williams, è l'opposto
del mio nome
Oh vero (Luigi)
Capito? Un bacio da Sheila
o se preferite da Jacqueline Salary
Oppure potrei chiamarmi tipo Haute Catrina, tipo Haute Couture
Fai come fanne le ragazze "Ho il rossetto sui denti" (Luigi)
Oh c'ho il rossetto sui denti
E no le ragazze fanno "così. Esatto"
Ho il rossetto sui denti
Mi fa troppo ridere, è ipnotico. Vabbè bella ragazzi finisco...
Bella ragazzi finisco ciao vado a dormire, no vado a mangiare. Ma io non ho mangiato
Oddio ottima dietra truccarsi. Adoro!
Anzi stavo ragionando su una cosa, fatemi
sapere quale potrebbe essere un buon nome da Drag
perché Jacqueline Salary è veramente na strappona, Sheila Williams è troppo tennista. Sono indecisa